der befürchtete horror im osten nena der
nur um eine sache es geht nicht darum
verhandelt schon vor dem krieg hat er
die fehlt mir tatsächlich in der
was in linz war was auf der krim war was
liebe das leben und ich möchte dass nun
wirklich kaum noch zu glauben
naiven friedens these vorteil das klingt
gesagt das darf nicht passieren darf es
hat begonnen putin will dort weitere
berichterstattung aber scholz hat das
niemand mehr sterben muss und ich kann
china oder die usa machen sondern es
keinen krieg zwischen bruder volker
vielen herzlichen dank paul ich würde
alles wahnsinnig toll aber wir machen
regionen erobern er will mario pohl so
ziel doch heute ganz klar formuliert
geben also wenn man jetzt versucht
geht darum dass russland hier einen
eine deiner fragen direkt auch mal an
russland darf nicht gewinnen das hat er
auch einen riesenfehler dass ist dieser
mir nicht vorstellen dass die ukraine
muss man es sagen klar machen das was er
angriffskrieg führt gegen ein souveränes
sozusagen die schuld bei der ukraine
was ein schritt der gedanke ist diesen
irrglaube denn jahrzehntelang auch die
frau guru weitergeben und zwar ist es
hier in kiew nicht geschafft hat was wir
gesagt und man kann ja auch nicht
oder den westlichen partnern zu nutzen
land es geht darum dass russland die
behaupten dass die bundesrepublik ist
krieg gewinnen kann sie kann ihn stoppen
oder das müsste man doch erstmal an
ihnen liebe zuschauer immer wieder
denn eigentlich richtig keine weiteren
medien geprägt hat wladimir putin will
dafür bekannt wäre dass wir in letzter
ukraine angegriffen hat es geht darum
verlangt das aufgeklappte hinzuschauen
sie kann den verlangsamen und wir und
gezeigt haben mein tier als ist die
zeit total übereilt gehandelt hätten
schweren waffen zu liefern in die
und auch wladimir putin zu schauen und
dass wladimir putin mit seinen truppen
doris pack der will ja nur so ein
offensive gab die soldaten uns hier
ukraine
jedoch allein 72 stunden 100 milliarden
wenn neue waffen kommen wird es noch
zu sehen was hier eigentlich passiert
also ich sag mal ich bin jetzt an der
hier kriegsverbrechen begeht und wenn
bisschen den kotau des westens nein
einkesseln wollten das haben sie nicht
dass ein kriegsverbrecher büro ich habe
zu bewilligen de aus einem
schrecklicher weil putin ja nicht sagt
wladimir putin hat ganz klar gesagt dass
geschafft und das gleiche versuchen sie
sie sagen und soll nicht kümmern was es
universität worden ja da ist bertha von
jetzt im dom bass und versuchen dort die
sondervermögen das ist eigentlich noch
suttner die erste frau die den
das gesehen in den straßen von butscher
oh gott jetzt kommen die waffen hoch
für bilder gibt und dass wenn moralische
aus seiner sicht die ukraine russland
jetzt muss ich aber aufhören nein er
gar nicht für die bundeswehr wurde die
friedensnobelpreis bekommen hat für den
gebiete zu nehmen
wie die menschen dort hingerichtet
überhöhung dann verstehe ich die welt
bundeswehr kann sie denn das für ein
satz die waffen nieder ja und ich frage
wurden von wladimir putins truppen mit
ist und er ist zu allem bereit er lässt
wird immer härter und furchtbar und
paul unser bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat
auftritt von olaf scholz also ich fand
brutale reagieren was ist ja wenn die
nicht mehr natürlich muss das kümmern
mich tatsächlich wenn wir anfang von
händen nach hinten wie sie hingerichtet
die menschen hinrichten die frauen
zum beispiel hat ein satz gesagt da hat
vor zwei stunden eine pressekonferenz
dass hier menschen hingerichtet werden
frieden frieden und nochmal frieden zu
werden vergewaltigt kinder werden
gehalten und verkündet dass die
wurden weil sie zivilisten weil sie
mich sehr bewegt weil er nämlich gar
ukraine am ende
reden ja weil wir einen ganz tragischen
nicht bewegend war er hat gesagt ich
sanktionen sehr deutliche wirkung zeigen
wir wollen dass hier menschen lasst mich
männer waren die dort einfach gelebt
umgebracht das ist die realität und
fast zerstört ist unzählige menschen tot
bitte ausreden lassen sie mich bitte
konflikt haben es wurde ja beschrieben
habe mit allen gesprochen ausführlich
haben also das gerede zu sagen das wird
zusagen wladimir putin muss man nur
und wir die ukraine militärisch und
ausreden ich habe sie auch ausreden
wir haben all die bilder vor augen aber
dann ist es operation gelungen und
finanziell unterstützen werden wie ist
lassen dass hier menschen hingerichtet
mir fehlt außer sehr vielen semantischen
irgendwie vielleicht auch einer
nicht genug über frieden gesprochen das
und wir haben klare prinzipien volle
patient tot also ich finde das einfach
deine sicht auf den heutigen auftritt
friedenskonferenz irgendwo einbinden
werden das darf uns nicht kalt lassen
kann ich wirklich nicht mehr hören hier
unterstützung und so weiter und so fort
äußerungen auch von dem amerikanischen
von olaf scholz was ja auch deine these
also ja
schrecklich ich würde so gerne auch
also ich habe mitnichten zu keinem
und dann hat er gesagt das leid lässt
das darf uns in einer politischen
präsidenten beiden ja der dritte
heute abend sein wird
sagen legt die waffen nieder aber
weltkrieg muss verhindert werden also
zeitpunkt gesagt dass ich der ukraine
niemanden kalt und er hat das so ohne
debatte nicht kalt das nein das darf es
natürlich wenn jetzt
auch schon diese setzungen die im
irgendwas in die schuhe schieben ich
so ist das nena ich habe mich heute über
jede wärme gesagt dass es mich fast
vorfeld ihnen ja ankündigen um ihn dann
habe nur versucht darüber nachzudenken
nicht und das sage ich ausdrücklich das
wenn wir das jetzt so eine kapitulation
diesen auftritt von olaf scholz
wie wir und im übrigen ist das was sie
zu verhindern wie auch immer mir fehlt
darf es über uns in der app auch nicht
sprachlos gesagt gemacht hat muss ich
wahnsinnig geärgert hier aus kiel
von den bagdad auch nicht und in kabul
in der gesamten sprache die ich seit
käme wie würde russland reagieren wie
gerade gesagt haben ein gutes beispiel
ehrlich sagen das war kein kommunikativ
auch nicht ja der punkt ist ja nur haben
blicken muss ich sagen warum hat er
dafür was mir an dieser
einiger zeit als ich sag mal tendenziell
starker auftritt nein nein das bin ich
ich in meinen träumen stelle ich mir vor
über bärlauch ist oder wenn wir das
kriegsberichterstattung tatsächlich seit
diese pressekonferenz überhaupt gegeben
eskalierend wahrnehmen fehlt mir einfach
allein ich fand diesen auftritt auch da
es gäbe eine große friedenskonferenz mit
nicht wollen und ich bin die erste die
beginn was mich auffällig stört ist ein
das war am ende selbst gerecht das war
bin ich auch bei den kollegen uns heimat
das reden über frieden denn was mir noch
das nicht will und habe das auch schon
dass dieser auftritt im grunde wie sie
ich nenne es mal moralischer überschuss
in anderen fernsehsendung gesagt wenn
nicht ganz klar ist ist was sind denn
arrogant wie er dort aufgetreten ist auf
haben gesagt nicht sagen ja also ich
experten mit politikern mit psycho mit
ja also krieg ist immer tragisch das ist
eigentlich die kriegsziele also die
wir das nicht wollen dann ist das ziel
die fragen der journalisten hat er nur
glaube auch wenn das übersetzt wird
militärischen ziele wer soll eigentlich
wissen die ukraine immer noch nicht was
den krieg zu beenden die waffen nieder
ganz schlimm was dort passiert auch ich
gesagt schauen sie sich doch um das
gegen wien gewinnen ja das scheint mir
coaches mit mit eine riesengroße
wir tun insofern war das 1 1 ein
gucke mir die bilder an aber der
und dann reden wir darüber wie wir das
ja nicht klar und solange das nicht
machen alle so wie ich und auch konkrete
bisschen durchgang bin ich völlig wein
möglich machen wir hatten die
konferenz des friedens und dazu wird
geklärt ist ist die forderung nach
fragen was jetzt mit schweren waffen ist
moralische überschuss und dieses gefühl
verhandlung in der türkei
also ich fand diese pressekonferenz auch
schweren waffen für mich keine
dass wir unter dem massiven druck von
mit nicht überzeugend und ein bisschen
was jetzt mit weiteren sanktionen ist
putin eingeladen weil was würde er denn
ist er tatsächlich noch nicht auf guten
emotionen handeln und große strategische
durchgemogelt und die ukraine wir wissen
berechtigte forderung die irgendetwas
hat er ausweichend oder gar nicht
klärt außer dies erklärt das mit mehr
immer noch nicht was wir jetzt bekommen
entscheidungen treffen das scheint mir
dann kommen das ist ja die frage
schuh erschienen das sehe ich auch aber
geantwortet klar ist olaf scholz will
schwere waffen ja nein und vielleicht ja
waffen und mehr geld für mehr waffen
immerhin dass in ihren die frage stelle
doch problematisch zurzeit zumindest das
ich wollte nur ganz generell sagen doch
wenn es unser oberstes ziel ist das
noch mehr krieg und leid geschehen wird
die ukraine nicht so unterstützen wie
würde ich darauf hinweisen wollen dass
sondern ich sage es müsste eine große
wir das bei anderen kriegen ganz egal ob
ich finde es gibt einen moralischen
gemetzel dort zu beenden dann reden wir
hier würde ich gern noch einmal bronze
die ukraine ist braucht er hat gesagt
weltumspannende konferenz geben das ist
in aleppo oder in bagdad wo die bilder
überschuss ich finde wir haben eine
heimat zurückholen bei der frage was
über den frieden und über verhandlungen
die ukrainische soldaten ich übersetze
ähnlich waren nicht getan haben und
wie so eine frau und dann müssten alle
relativ denn ein moralischer eine
über angebote die dazu führen können
sind die militärischen kriegsziele die
das einmal frei die seien zu blöd um die
insofern habe ich ja nur gesagt was sind
das geht tatsächlich
über diesen frieden reden und der putin
frau gerade im raum gestellt hat paul
dann reden wir eben nicht immer schwerer
die kriegsziele weil was putin sagt das
deutschen panzer zu fahren das würde
waffen das wäre nur ein punkt holen wir
will nur eines der verlangt eigentlich
es geht um eine welle von empathie und
jetzt zu lange dauert also deswegen
ist mir klar und das höre ich und ich
einmal doch frau regina ich meine ja
sage noch mal dass ich weder den
diese panzer nicht er hat außerdem
und das ist glaube ich der hauptgrund
ja ich bin da relativ sprachlos
eine welle von gefühlen mit der ein
wenn ihr meint was zur berichterstattung
angriffskrieg entschuldige noch dass ich
sagen kann dann ja wohl frau riekel ja
gesagt dass man weitere schwere waffen
strategisches geschehen beurteilt wird
der verlangt einen kotau eine eine
ehrlicher sah ehrlicherweise denn die
den aggressor hier er rechtfertige noch
aus deutschland eben nicht einsetzen
teilweise in deutschen medien so kommt
ich muss schon sagen dass ich ihnen sehr
kriegsziele gerade von wladimir putin
verbeugung der verlangt etwas womit er
dass sich der ukraine keine schuld
will er hat nicht mehr das in den mund
es mir vor relativ ungefiltert
nahe bin
sind ja klar frau büro die hat gesagt er
zuschieben aber was sind die
genommen aus sicht der ukraine aus der
dann alle siegesparaden prahlen und
was heißt russland darf diesen krieg
europäischen in diesem fall europäischen
ukrainische position ja damit will ich
will die ukraine vernichten die ukraine
perspektive der ukraine am tag als
krieg seele wollen wir die russisch
hat auf sicht sei dies kein
nicht gewinnen
weder irgendetwas entschuldigen noch
herumspazieren kann denn er ist kein
dieses land erneut eine großoffensive
wollen wir russland besiegen wollen wir
existenzrecht er hat gesagt er will
irgendetwas machen das einzige was ich
was bedeutet das jetzt wird russland
mann der aufgegeben hat und das ist
wie das ja sozusagen auch im senat wird
sage ist dass man zwischen einer
über sich ergehen lassen muss im osten
tiert übernehmen er hat gesagt hier will
das war ja jetzt vor ein paar tagen
strategischen diskussion über die dinge
meine große große große sorge ich bin ja
nicht gewinnen heißt das dass die
die menschen sterben in mariupol kinder
diese große eskalation über beiden
er sagen das ist sein mag er gesagt das
ukraine gewinnt meinte sympathie meine
die hier diskutiert werden und das sind
noch mal so ein bisschen wie bioware
wollen wir einen regime change wollen
und frauen eingeschlossen sind ein
viele dinge ja da geht es um das münster
ist russland also die ziele formuliert
points hammer würde er hier sitzen bin
deutscher bundeskanzler der sich dorthin
wir sozusagen das wiederholen was die
bewunderung ja gehört diesen tapfer
abkommen und den ukrainisch-russischen
von wladimir putin sind völlig klar und
ich aber die these macht deswegen ich
konflikt um ge um die krim und was auch
amerikaner in bagdad 2003 gemacht haben
stellt und eigentlich nichts zu
habe ihn schon wieder im oft gehört und
wenn sie sagen keiner wenn über frieden
männern in der ukraine ganz klar aber
wäre das eine realistische zielsetzung
verkünden hat der hätte dass sein dass
immer da geht es aber auch im
würde jetzt noch einmal sam rüber
sprechen doch wie zuletzt die der
amerikanisch chinesische interessen um
scheiden zur erwiderung habe
das sind die fragen und diese fragen
der dass sein dass müssen am ende auch
wenn ich eine mutter wäre
erdöl und gas und so weiter und dass man
ukrainische präsident will ständig über
und vor allem wenn man dann einen blick
halbwegs diszipliniert und nüchtern zu
ja ich habe so ein bisschen das gefühl
das sozusagen
frieden sprechen er sagt immer wieder
und ich wüsste mein sohn musste camp
auf die spd macht die anstatt sich mit
dass ich nicht mal führte nach acht
unabhängigen dann diskutieren können
diskutieren ohne in den moralischen
seit beginn des krieges ich bin bereit
geschaltet bin sondern weil ein oster
mich mit tutti nach ein tisch lasst uns
überschuss zu gehen dass in kiew
sich selbst zu beschäftigen nämlich mit
müsste und nicht sofort gemeldet hier
hineingehen ich würde meinen sohn packen
friedens nach keine friedens thesen
den fragen was eigentlich in der spd los
tragischerweise nicht nur kiew in der
und würde mit ihnen auswandern oder
war in den letzten jahrzehnten in den
sonst wohin gehen ich alles aus mir
ukraine tragischerweise menschen sterben
letzten jahren gehen sie auf den
das scheint mir tatsächlich das gebot
spricht dass sich die journalistin
ukrainischen botschafter los und das ist
sondern als mir spricht eine frau
der stunde und die zurückhaltung ja um
sozusagen die an das bewahrende und ich
diese diskrepanz noch mal zu machen die
[Musik]